i'm so grateful for the show because it
got me to where i am today and uh it's
helped me you know with so many
opportunities grateful for dance moms
but maddie ziegler is okay with leaving
one part in the past her former dance
coach abby lee miller they distanced
themselves all of them
all the kids all the moms
act as if
i had nothing to do with the show nor my
studio
maddie is cosmopolitan's latest cover
star and she opens up to the mag about
her current relationship with abby which
she says is non-existent maddie reveals
she hasn't spoken to her former dance
coach since she and her sister kenzie
left the lifetime show and abby's dance
company in 2016. you need to get into
the groove and you need to be my number
one girl out there every week again do
you understand that yes
maddie says of abby she trained me she
helped me but also i knew i would be
okay without her and i was sick of being
in a toxic environment i was like this
is not for me i can't do this the dancer
turned actress initially felt guilty for
leaving and was distraught for a long
time but now maddie says she's at peace
with where she stands with abby and her
dancing past i'm just happy now there is
one dance mom star that will always show
love to abby jojo siwa i
will always remember where i came from
when e.t caught up with the triple
threat earlier this year she had nothing
but nice words to say about her former
coach
everyone had a different experience with
abby and a different experience with
dance moms i think entering the show as
a big fan i left the show still a big
fan and i you know obviously i'm not a
fan girl of the show but i really
respect the show and i respect what the
show did for the dance world and for you
know for me for maddie for kalani for
kendall for nia um for kenzie abby
actually taught me a lot you know abby
has a lot of dance knowledge and and i i
carry a lot of what she taught me with
me drama aside one thing is for sure the
girls got lifelong friendships thanks to
the show dance moms celebrated its 10th
anniversary last year and maddie told et
those bonds are stronger than ever who
do you stay the closest with oh my god
i'm close to all of them i live like
four minutes from nia so we literally
live so close so i'm i see her a lot
it's so interesting to hang out as
adults now i mean young adults like it's
amazing and we're all such great friends
and i love them to death and we've been
on such a wild ride together so it's
it's crazy
[Music]